und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihn allen wenn es
eine Gegend auf der Welt gibt in der
wirklich alles mit allem zusammenhängt
dann ist das der Nahe Osten wo
vergleichsweise kleine Auslöser zu einem
Flächenbrand führen können und häufig
führen heute meldet der Iran einen
verheerenden Anschlag fast 100 Tote bei
mehreren Explosionen 30 lebensgefährlich
verletzte der tödlichste Anschlag in der
Geschichte der Islamischen Republik in
der Stadt Kerman hatten sich Systemtreue
regierungsanhänger versammelt anlässlich
des Todestages eines ehemals sehr
mächtigen iranischen Generals der war
von den USA vor vier Jahren mit einem
Drohnenangriff getötet worden beim
Anschlag heute stellt sich die Frage wer
steckt dahinter Anna Feist berichtet
mit Süßigkeiten und Suppe wie an einem
Feiertag begehen Sie hier in theeran den
vierten Todestag ihres Volkshelden
Kassim sleimani einst Anführer der
alkutzbrigaden dann wurde er auf Trumps
Befehl von einer Drohne liquidiert die
Erinnerung an ihn ist Ehrensache so ist
das was nun folgen wird ein Schlag ins
Herz des regims zeitgleich an der
Grabstelle von suleimani in Kerman im
Süden des
iransus Versam sich zur Gedenkfeier
plötzlich hört man zwei
Explosionen offiziell heißt es 95 Tote
und fast 200 verletzte das Regime
spricht von einer Terrorattacke auf das
Grab eines ihrer wichtigsten
Vertreter was steckt
dahinter das war eine Warnung an das
islamische
Regime glaubt nicht dass ihr zu sicher
seid dass ihr zu stark
seid
doch wer hinter dem Anschlag steckt
weiter unklar nur so viel der Anschlag
trifft da wo es weh tut kim suleimani
war einer der wichtigsten Berater von
Revolutionsführer aliamenei sein Erbe
nährt heute den Krieg in Nahost
suleimani hat die alkutz Brigaden
angeführt die Militäreinheit des Irans
im Ausland ihr Ziel die Eroberung
Jerusalems und die Zerstörung Israels
seine Truppen Bauten Terrororganisation
wie die
Libanon und die Hamas in Gaza auf aufan
Straßen ist der Schuldige für den
Angriff deshalb schnell
gefunden verflucht sind sie natürlich
steckt Israel dahinter alles Schlechte
kommt daher Teufel sind
das das waren die Amerikaner und die
Israelis unsere Feinde die unser Land
bedrohen sicher werden die Finger nun
erstmal auf Israel zeigen aberit wir
wissen wurden keine hochrangigen
Personen
getötet deshalb halte ich das für
[Musik]
unwahrscheinlich Israel würde nicht so
wahlos
angreifen die Suche nach dem Täter hat
gerade erst begonnen schriftlich
verspricht am Abend der iranische
Präsident raisi seinen Anhängern die
Schuldigen dieser feigenat würden bald
ermittelt und für ihre abscheuliche Tat
bestraft
werden ja alles hängt mit allem zusammen
im Nahen Osten habe ich vorhin schon
gesagt angesichts des todestages des
iranischen Generals hat der Chef der
schiitenmiliz Hisbollah im Libanon heute
eine Rede angekündigt die noch aus
anderen Gründen mit Hochspannung
erwartet wurde denn gestern gab es
mitten in Beirut einen Mordanschlag mit
sieben Toten brisant ist wer dabei
getroffen wurde ein hauptstrippenzieher
der palästinensischen Maß und mehrere
seiner Leute brisant ist wo der Anschlag
stattfand in einem Gebiet das hisbolla
Hochburg ist und indem es so etwas seit
dem Ende des letzten Libanonkrieges vor
fast 20 Jahren nicht mehr gegeben hatte
brisant ist auch wie Israel den
nahelegenden Verdacht dahinter zu
stecken geradezu genüsslich durch die
Blume kommentiert und brisant ist dass
all das nicht ohne Folgen bleiben wird
denn sowohl hammas als auch b sehen sich
jetzt unter Zugzwang Susanna Santina mit
mehr dass sich die meisten Menschen im
Libanon mit den Palästinensern
solidarisieren sieht man sofort aber die
Sorge vor einer Eskalation des Konflikts
ist auch bei ihnen groß im Süden an der
Grenze zu Israel haben viele aus Angst
sogar ihre Häuser
verlassen das libanesische Volk ist
nicht bereit für diesen Krieg wir haben
keine Bunker wenn ein Krieg ausbricht wo
sollen wir uns in Sicherheit
bringen ich hoffe dass sich die Lage
beruhigt der Libanon kann keinen Krieg
verkraften die wenigsten hier zweifeln
daran wer hinter dem drohenangriff in
berut steckt bei dem gestern Abend unter
anderem der Hamas fieze allarudi getötet
wurde es gibt nach wie vor keine
offizielle Bestätigung Israels aber
bezeichnen die Äußerung des Chefs des
israelischen
Geheimdienstes der mossat sieht sich
verpflichtet die Mörder und Planer des
Attentats vom 7 oktober zur Rechenschaft
zu ziehen
auch wenn es insgesamt einige Zeit
dauern
wird s alarudi wird für mehrere
Terroranschläge verantwortlich gemacht
und galt als Nummer 2 hinter hamaschef
Ismail Hania der bestätigte auch den Tod
von zwei Kommandeuren des militärischen
arms der
Hammers wir bestätigen die Ermordung
durch die zionistische Besatzungsmacht
unseres großen Bruders und kampfesführer
alarui und seiner Brüder es war ein
Terrorakt der die Souveränität des
Libanon verletzt hat eine erneute
Feindseligkeit gegen unser
Volk die Tötung des gesuchten
Topterroristen sei ein herberschlag für
die Hamas sagt Politikwissenschaftler
har für den islamischen dihad oder Dieb
im Iran war ja auch wichtig aber war der
Chef des Terrorismus schon vor dem 7
Oktober ein Kopf des Terrors der jetzt
ausgeschaltet wurde insofern schwächt
sein Tod natürlich die
Hamas
am Abend hält hisbolla Führer nasralla
eine mit Spannung erwartete Rede der
Hamas spricht er sein Beileid aus und
nennt den Angriff in Beirut eine
Aggression Israels eine konkrete Drohung
wiederholt er
nicht längst hat sich im Norden für
Israel eine neue Front gebildet und auch
die Angehörigen der immer noch 129
Geiseln sind jetzt in großer
Sorge Hamas hat gleich nach dem Angriff
gesagt alle Verhandlungen natürlich wird
das nicht
helfen allarudi ist von Gott geliebt
rufen Sie im Westjordanland wo heute
Hunderte Menschen gegen die gezielte
Tötung in berut
demonstrieren große Solidarität mit der
Hamas die Gefahr eines Flächenbrandes im
Nahen Osten ist derzeit sehr
groß jetzt mal diese verschiedenen
Entwicklungen miteinander zu verknüpfen
und das machen wir mit unserer
Korrespondentin für die arabische Welt
mit goline atai in Kairo goline guten
Abend kann man denn sagen und wir
beginnen vielleicht mit dem verheerenden
Anschlag heute im Iran wer am Esten ein
Interesse daran hat so einen Anschlag zu
verüben nun rassim soimani war eine
mythische Figur er hat sich viele Feinde
gemacht im Innern des Landes es hat in
den vergangenen Monaten unzähige
brennende suimani Karte gegeben hat sich
aber auch viele Feinde gemacht beim
Kampf gegen den is in Irak aber auch bei
der Unterstützung von Assad in Syrien wo
er gnadenlos gegen die Zivilbevölkerung
vorgegangen ist Irans Regime hat bei
solchen Anschlägen in der Vergangenheit
immer wieder sunitische Gruppierungen
beschuldigt wie z.B einen
is-ableger es hat aber auch eine
bewaffnete Gruppierung innerhalb der
iranischen
auslandsopposition beschuldigt es gibt
noch einen anderen Verdacht und den teil
sehr sehr viele im Iran so ungeheuerlich
er auch klingen mag dass das Regime
diesen Anschlag selbst verübt habe so
heißt es vor allen Dingen um die
Repression noch zu steigern innerhalb
des Landes und die Bevölkerung hinter
einem äußerst unbeliebten Regime zu
sammeln im März finden Parlamentswahlen
im Iran statt und das Regime tut sich im
Moment sehr sehr schwer Interesse
seitens der Bevölkerung dafür zu wecken
also alles noch sehr unklar und
einigermaßen nebulös schauen wir gol auf
die andere Entwicklung in Israel heißt
es ja mittlerweile ganz offen wir haben
es vorhin im Film auch kurz gesehen dass
eine Jagd läuft auf die Hintermänner des
Hamas Massakers vom 7 Oktober so ein
bisschen ähnlich der Aktion nach dem
Olympia Massaker von München als der
mossart damals in aller Welt die drazier
umbrachte und dabei auch völlig
unschuldige traf muss man sagen jetzt
also dieser Anschlag in birut auf die
Hamas Führung in Hisbollah Gebiet welche
Antwort wird es darauf
geben
ich glaube wenn man nach der heutigen
Rede von Hassan dasasraller geht dem
Generalsekretär wird es einen
Vergeltungsschlag geben irgendwann
irgendwo ich muss sagen ich habe heute
einen müdewikenden Hassan nasralla
erlebt in seiner Rede einen eher
zurückhaltenden eher bedachten das heißt
diese Antwort wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwie sorgsam sorgfältig abgewogen
sein es könnte ein Schlag sein der etwas
tiefer ins Innere des israelischen
Territoriums zielt ein Schlag der
vielleicht Israels
gasförderanlagen ins Visier nimmt aber
ein vollumfänglicher Krieg muss ich
sagen nach heutigem Stand scheint immer
noch nicht im Interesse der hisbolla zu
liegen eher scheint mir im Moment der
Ball auf Israels Feld zu liegen wo sich
doch immer wieder Stimmen mehren
mononach es eines Präventivschlags
bedürfte um die hisbolla aus dem
Grenzgebiet zu entfernen wir erinnern
uns nach der letzten unresolution dürfte
die hisboll eigentlich gar nicht im
Grenzgebiet operieren nur die
libanesische Armee dürfte nur dort sein
nur die UN Friedenstruppen dürften dort
sein aber die hisbolla hat sich nie an
diese UN-Resolution gehalten im
Hintergrund laufen Verhandlungen der
Amerikaner mit der hiszbolla sie zum
Rückzug zu bewegen aber im Moment
weigert sie sich auch mit dem Verweis
darauf dass Israel bestimmte Gebiete in
der Grenzregion nicht aufgeben würde
jetzt kann ja aber eigentlich niemand an
einem wirklich großen Krieg an Israels
Nordgrenze mit dem Libanon wirklich
interessiert sein oder denn was würde
der bedeuten für die gesamte Region
inklusive
Iran so ein Schlag würde verheerend sein
vor allen Dingen für Israel denn wir
können nicht die Hamas mit der hisbolla
vergleichen wir können nicht die
hamasraketen mit der mit den hisbolla
Raketen vergleichen die wahrscheinlich
über 100.000 wenn nicht gar 150 000
Raketen der hisbolla sind
Präzisionsraketen sie haben modernste
Sprengköpfe diebolla wäre wirklich auch
in der Lage mit einem Flugabwehrsystem
mit mit sehr vielen Mitteln auch Israels
Schiffsverkehr lahm zu legen also es
wäre wirklich verherend eigentlich kann
niemand daran ein Interesse haben und
sämtliche Kriegsschauplätze die wir
jetzt schon angespannt sehen in Irak in
Syrien im Jemen wäre noch viel mehr mit
hineingezogen goline ganz herzlichen
Dank für diese Einordnungen für uns alle
hier heute Abend live aus Kairo goline
artei war das und damit jetzt hier heute
Abend im heute schournal zu einem
weiteren Thema dass wir heute
fortschreiben müssen Hanna mit dir ja
ganz genau nach dem schweren Erdbeben in
Japan ist die Zahl der Todesopfer auf
mindestens 73 gestiegen die Strom und
Wasserversorgung ist an manchen Orten
noch immer unterbrochen rettungskräfte
versuchen unter Hochdruck Menschen noch
lebend aus den Trümmern zu bergen oft
allerdings vergeblich die Rettung sei
ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit so Japans
Minister Präsident kishida mehr als
30.000 Menschen sind in
Evakuierungszentren untergebracht die
Wetterbehörde warnt vor möglichen
weiteren
Erdrutschen wir bleiben in Japan denn es
gibt neue Erkenntnisse zu dem tödlichen
Zusammenstoß zweier Flugzeuge auf dem
Flughafen Tokio Haneda demnach war die
Kollision vermutlich die Folge eines
menschlichen Fehlers die japanische
Nachrichtenagentur Kyodo berichtet unter
Berufung auf das
Verkehrsministerium dass das kleinere
Flugzeug der Küstenwache keine Erlaubnis
gehabt habe sich auf die ST und
Landebahn zu begeben das gehe aus dem
Funkverkehr zwischen den Flugzeugen und
dem Tower
hervor die Ukraine und Russland haben
nach eigenen Angaben eine große Zahl von
Kriegsgefangenen ausgetauscht laut Kiev
wurden 230 Ukraina freigelassen das
russische Verteidigungsministerium
sprach seinerseits von
248 russischen Soldaten die entlassen
wurden nach ukrainischen Angaben
handelte es sich um den größten
Gefangenen Austausch seit des russischen
angriffskriegs in der Türkei hat fast
ein Jahr nach der verheerenden
Erdbebenkatastrophe ein erster Prozess
wegen mutmaßlicher Baumängel begonnen
konkret geht es um den Einsturz eines
vier Sterne Hotels angeklagt sind der
Besitzer und zehn weitere Personen ihnen
wird vorgeworfen für den Tod von 72
Menschen verantwortlich zu sein zum
Prozessbeginn reisten zahlreiche
Angehörige der Opfer an unter den Toten
war waren auch 26 Kinder aus einem
Volleyballteam die Rechnung jetzt ist
einfach und bedrohlich zugleich je
stärker je ausdauernder es regnet desto
größer die Gefahr das Deiche brechen
dass die Situation in den deutschen
Hochwassergebieten außer Kontrolle gerät
der Deutsche Wetterdienst hat seine
Warnung vor Dauerregen gerade bis
Samstag verlängert außer Niedersachsen
blicken jetzt weitere Bundesländer mit
Sorge auf ihre Flüsse die bislang noch
von Überschwemmungen verschont waren
gestern sah die Karte mit Warnungen vor
extrem Hochwasser noch so aus heute sind
mehrere Gebiete dazuekommen vor allem in
Sachsen-Anhalt aber auch in Hessen und
in Bayern Fabian Köhler hat die
Übersicht rund um den Ort Markt Redwitz
in Oberfranken hat sich das Wasser der
kössein stark ausgebreitet mitten im
Dorf stehen Weiden und Sportanlagen
unter Wasser der kleine Fluss ist zu
einem breiten Strom angeschwollen reicht
bis an die ersten Häuser her R an viele
Straßen sind unpassierbar
deutschlandweit sorgen starke Regenfälle
für neue überschwemmung in Regionen die
bislang er verschont blieben die
Gemeinde nonweiler im Saarland auch der
Katastrophenschutz kann manche Gebäude
nicht mehr schützen schnell sucht sich
das Wasser seinen Weg sogar ein gesamtes
Industriegebiet in Otzenhausen wurde von
Wassermassen überflutet weil ein
umestürzter Baum im Bachlauf gelegen hat
und das Wasser das Massiv dort
hinabgestömt ist in die Firmen die dort
ansäsig waren eingeflossen sind wie hier
bleibt auch die Lage besonders im
Nordwesten von Niedersachsen weiter
angespannt ein rund 2 km langer mobiler
Deich soll Teile der Stadt Oldenburg im
absoluten Ernstfall schützen seit
einigen Tagen droht hier eine
teilevakuierung der Wasserstand der
Hunde unverändert hoch die
Dauerbelastung für alle beteidigten
extrem und dennoch im Krisenzentrum
braucht es manchmal auch norddeutsche
Gelassenheit Tumor sicherlich eine der
wichtigsten Mittel die man
aufrechterhalten muss Stimmung muss
weiter gut sein obwohl es sehr
angespannte Lage ist manche einer von
uns war Heiligabend oder auch Silvester
nicht bei seiner Familie und das zT
natürlich auch durchaus ein bisschen
Niedersachsen hat inzwischen 1,9
Millionen Sandsäcke aus der eigenen
Reserve verbaut jetzt haben andere
Bundesländer weitere 1,5 Millionen zur
Verfügung gestellt Unterstützung auch
aus dem Ausland diese französische
zivilschutzeinheit hat unter anderem
anen 1,5 km langen Hochwasserdeich im
Gepäck der Nahe Winsen aufgebaut werden
soll im Süden von Niedersachsen ist die
Leine zwar noch nicht zurück im
eigentlichen Flussbett doch der Pegel
sinkt langsam in einigen Orten soll ab
morgen bereits der Rückbau der Dämme
beginnen wenn aus Eckern und Weiden
ganze Seenlandschaften geworden sind
wenn Hofeinfahrten unter Wasser stehen
und die Keller voll laaufen dann kann
man sich auch als nichtlandwirt
vorstellen wie alle die ihr Geld mit
Ackerbau und Viehzucht verdienen die uns
versorgen mit Lebensmitteln gerade
besonders zu bangen haben und zu leiden
man ist gerade so voll mit Adrenalin
heißt es heute vom bremischen
landwirtschaftsverband
keineiklas in Bremen timmersl an der
Grenze zu Niedersachsen sind die Schäden
die das Hochwasser angerichtet hat immer
noch nicht ganz absehbar der Nachbarhof
von Landwirt Karsten Schnakenberg musste
gar evakuiert werden er selbst konnte
seine Kälbchen gerade noch ins Trockene
retten denn sein 18 185 erbauter Hof
liegt auf einer Warft trotzdem versanken
nicht nur Teile seiner Futtermittel in
den Fluten ja das ist backy das ist
pitche nass noch ist es nicht muffig
aber das nasse wenn das jetzt abtrocknet
dann wird das
wird das zeitnmuffig ne und auf dem
Schaden bleiben sie sitzen da bleiben
wir drauf sitzen ja das das bezahlt
keiner einen Steinwurf weiter bringen in
Liliental ein paar Einwohner ihre
Habseligkeiten in Sicherheit während der
niedersächsische Umwelt Minister Meer
und die grüne parteischiff in lang die
Nachbargemeinde Bremens besuchen die
grünen Politiker setzen sich für die
Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse ein und
versprechen finanzielle Hilfen wir haben
das beim
al gesagt und das gilt für mich genauso
für diese Flut niemand darf mit diesen
Schäden alleinelassen werden gerade auch
im
ahal sehen wir ja jetzt auch es ist
teilweise Geld genug da aber es
scheitert einfach an der Bürokratie und
an der
Verteilung und ich denke dass wir da von
der Politik nicht ganz viel erwarten
können da bin ich ganz ehrlich die
Weideflächen überflutet das Hochwasser
in die Gemäuer seines Hofes gekrochen
versucht Landwirt Karsten Schnakenberg
zu retten was zu retten ist doch der
beste Hochwasserschutz offenbar der
seiner Vorfahren wenn man unser Haus
hier sieht das ist 1885 gebaut das ist
auch nach WF gebaut früher gab es hier
kein Deich kein gar nichts hier hat das
Wasser bis ans Haus gestanden aber die
Häuser sind nicht abgesoffen und das
kann man ja auch wenn man jetzt so über
Land fährt genau sehen auch hier in der
Siedlung da sind auch Häuser die sind 80
Jahre alt
die stehen hoch und die die in den 80er
Jahren gebaut worden sind die stehen
halt niedrig den Kuhstall hat der
Landwirt auch auf Höhe seines
Haupthauses errichten lassen s dass die
Kühe zwar den dieser Tage unvermeidbaren
Seeblick haben aber eben keine nassen
Hufe der deutscher Arbeitsmarkt hat zwei
komplett entgegengesetzte Seiten die
eine Seite ist geprägt von der schwachen
Wirtschaftsentwicklung sie betrifft
speziell Menschen die weniger
qualifiziert sind und es immer schwerer
haben eine Stelle zu finden und
Jahreszeit spielt auch eine Rolle die
aktuellen Zahlen für den Dezember heute
rausgekommen sehen dementsprechend so
aus insgesamt waren
2637 000 Menschen auf Jobsuche das sind
31 000 mehr als im November die Quote
stieg auf
5,7%. gegenüber dem Vorjahresmonat stieg
die Zahl der Arbeitslosen um
183 000 jetzt die andere Seite die
bleibt ein großes Thema auch im gerade
begonnenen Jahr speziell in
Dienstleistungsberufen wird händeringend
Personal gesucht das Wort
Fachkräftemangel bleibt für Deutschlands
Wirtschaft in aller Munde und ein
riesenprem im Osten des Landes noch mal
aus besonderen Gründen wie Melanie Haak
zeigt nugard vom Band 3000 Tonnen im
Jahr in Südthüringen produziert fiber
süßw
Packer Anlagenführer Verkäufer kaum eine
Schicht ohne ausländische Mitarbeiter
wie Vlada ZKA aus der
Ukraine für mich ist die Arbeit wichtig
ich kann meine Rechnungen bezahlen und
ich kann in Deutschland
leben die Arbeit der Einstieg für die
23-Jährige geflüchtete in den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt Integration am
Band ich habe nach einem Deutschkurs
gesucht aber ich habe bislang keinen
gefunden
meine mir mit Händen und Füßen notfalls
muss man auch mal was auf dem Blatt
Papier malen um es irgendwie
verständlich zu machen Mitarbeiter aus
17 Nationen sind bei dem Mittelständler
beschäftigt die Firma hilft bei der
Wohnungssuche bietet Fahrgemeinschaften
und Sprachkurse hier auf dem Land sonst
schwer zu finden dennoch 25 Stellen sind
ausgeschrieben und viele Hürden zu hoch
findet die Chefin rein faktisch brauchen
wir die Zuwanderung aus dem Ausland der
der demografische Wandel ist so
eindeutig wir als Unternehmen würden uns
wünschen dass die bürokratischen Hürden
für die Integration ausländischer
Fachkräfte herabgesetzt würden damit es
einfacher wird diese diesen Schritt zu
gehen bundesweit beeinflusst der
Fachkräfte Mangel 39% der Unternehmen in
ihrer
Geschäftstätigkeit laut Bundesagentur
verarbeit funktioniere das
Beschäftigungswachstum nur noch durch
Zuwanderung wir haben einige Hörden die
wir beseitigen müssen beispielsweise
sehr langwierige Anerkennungsverfahren
wenn die Leute mit einer Qualifikation
kommen dauert es lange bis man in
Deutschland das anerkennt oder auch
Ausländer behehörden die teilweise
personell einfach unterbesetzt sind
trotzdem würde ich sagen insgesamt ist
was in Bewegung gekommen auch durch das
neue Fachkräfte einwänderungsgesetz in
und aus in Erfurt malt der Präsident der
Industrie und Handelskammer den
Thüringer Arbeitsmarkt auf A4 ihn treibt
die Stimmung vor den Landtagswahlen im
Herbst und die AFD seine Sorge das Image
des Wirtschaftsstandorts ich kann n
jedem empfehlen der glaubt
und das kann ich teilweise sogar gut
verstehen den etablierten Parteien mal
die rote Karte zeigen zu wollen sich
viel stärker mit der Politik beschäftigt
und vor allen sich auch mal das
Wahlprogramm der AFD anguckt die ja z.B
aus der EU austreten will ja laut
Wahlprogramm Thüringen Fieber wirbt für
ein weltoffenes Thüringen das in vielen
Branchen längst auf ausländische
Arbeitskräfte angewiesen ist in den
letzten 10 Jahren hat sich ihre Zahl
verfünffacht um einerseits Fachkräfte
nach Thüringen zu holen und aber auch
hier in Thüringen zu halten ist es
wichtig dass sich die Menschen hier
wohlfühlen und dass wir alle hier auch
wieder sehen wie viel Gutes wir zu
bieten haben das Unternehmen wird jetzt
einen
Integrationsbeauftragten einstellen um
die edingungen für ausländische
Arbeitskräfte weiter
anzupassen so jetzt noch eine
interessante statistische Größe mit di
Hanna der größte e-autobauer der Welt
heißt nicht mehr Tesla der Konzern von
Elon Musk wurde im letzten Quartal 2023
von seinem chinesischen Konkurrenten BYD
überholt und Valerie Haller experten
sehen sogar noch weiteres
Wachstumspotenzial bei BYD ja richtig
ein Erfolgsrezept ist die Strategie fast
alles selbst zu produzieren BYD stellt
Chips her kontrolliert Minen und baut
seine eigenen Batterien die sind ja
sozusagen das Herzstück eines E-Autos
und vermutlich auch das teuerste Teil ja
die eigene Produktion die hält eben die
Kosten in Schach ein enormer
Wettbewerbsvorteil vor allem wenn man es
wie BYD auf den Massenmarkt abgesehen
hat außerdem kann sich BYD der
Rückendeckung durch die eigene Regierung
sicher sein auch in Form von
Subventionen und die plant nichts
Geringeres als die weltweite Führung bei
E-Autos was bedeutet dieser Aufstieg von
BYD denn für die deutschen Autobauer wo
stehen die weltweit in Sachen E-Autos
also Premiumhersteller wie BMW und
Mercedes werden noch etwas weniger hart
getroffen von der Konkurrenz aus China
eher Hersteller die es auf den
Massenmarkt abgesehen haben Autobauer
wie VW hinken da noch hinterher müssen
die Kosten in den Griff bekommen aber
batteriefabriken sind im Bau und die
deutschen Hersteller können noch auf
finanzielle Polster aus dem
verbrennersegment zurückgreifen und
dieses Geld in neuere Technologien
investieren also das Rennen ist noch
nicht entschieden vielen Dank Valerie
für deine
Einschätzungen im vergangenen Jahr ist
in Deutschland erstmals mehr als die
Hälfte des Stroms aus erneuerbaren
Energien erzeugt worden das hat die
Bundesnetzagentur mitgeteilt der Anteil
lag 2022 noch knapp darunter bei rund
48% 2023 waren es 55
den größten Beitrag dazu leisteten
Windenergieanlagen gefolgt von
Fotovoltaik und
Biomasse zu den Lottozahlen die lauten
14 25 28 32
3649 Superzahl 4 alle Angaben wie immer
ohne Gewehr wie auch in den vergangenen
Tagen gibt es weiterhin eine
Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes vor ergiebigem Dauer
Regen in mehreren Teilen
Deutschlands bei der vierchanzenournee
bleibt es spannend nach dem heutigen
springen auf der
bergiselschanze hat Andreas Wellinger
die Gesamtführung verloren und liegt nun
hinter dem Japaner Kobayashi allerdings
nur
knapp im ersten Durchgang hat Andreas
Wellinger mit 132 m ein Statement
gesetzt dann der zweite Sprung zu kurz
Absprung nicht getroffen der ungünstig
nur
126,5 m Wellinger enttäuscht aber er
bekommt Pluspunkte für die
Windverhältnisse und lächelt dann doch
noch Podest verpasst aber Platz 5 ja wir
haben gewusst dass es ein bisschen der
windlotterie wird die war jetzt nicht
unbedingt der glücklichste im zweiten
aber vom Sprung selber von der Energie
vom Fluss war der schon ziemlich gut die
Chance auf den Gesamtsieg hat er sich
bewahrt sein größter Konkurrent rioyo
Kobayashi schnappt sich zwar die Führung
in der turnwertung liegt aber nur 4,8
Punkte vor Wellinger das dritte springen
in Innsbruck gewonnen hat der
Österreicher Jan
hör jetzt geht's weiter mit unserer
nächtlichen Tour im ZDF durch die mega
cities dieser Welt und wer gestern in
China mit dabei war wird es kaum
erwarten können die Nacht in Mexico City
heute früher gefürchtet für
Bandenkriminalität jetzt ein Hotspot von
Feinschmeckern Künstlern und für laute
Partys das alles gleich nach uns hier ja
und gegen 0 Uhr 15 gibt's dann unser
heute journal Update und zwar mit
Gundula Gause und von allen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen auch den hinter den Kameras
an sie einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend kaum ist das Tief
Anneli morgen nach Osten abgezogen kommt
hier von Frankreich schon gleich das
nächste Tief Brigitta hinterher das sind
keine guten Aussichten für die
hochwasserregionen in Schleswig-Holstein
Hamburg und Niedersachsen in Sachsen
anhall Thüringen Hessen Bayern und
Nordrhein-Westfalen denn es drohen
weitere stauniederschläge heute Nacht
vor allen Dingen hier im Sauerland im
Südwesten kann es auch mal für Blitz und
Donner reichen und im Norden mischen
sich einige Schneeflocken unter den
Regen da dreht der Wind auf Nord und es
wird schon in der Nacht recht kalt da
sinken die Werte auf 0° sonst liegen die
nachtwerte noch bei recht milden 8 bis
3°. und morgen wird es im Norden kaum
milder 1° sind dann die
Höchsttemperaturen in Schleswig-Holstein
sonst werden Werte zwischen 3 und 11°
erreicht und doch morgen bleibt es also
bei Schneeregen hier im Nordosten sonst
ist es meist bedeckt und es regnet zum
Teil noch richtig ergiebig weiter
besonders wieder im Sauerland im
Südwesten zeigt sich dagegen vor allen
Dingen am Nachmittag auch mal häufiger
die Sonne und wenn Sie sich fragen wo
denn wohl der Winter bleibt na derzeit
liegt der über Skandinavien mit
kräftigem Dauerfrost aber bis zum Anfang
der kommenden Woche kann sich dieser
Dauerfrost auch bei uns in Deutschland
durchsetzen im Nordosten erwarten wir
dann durchaus Dauerfrost von um die
-5°. vorher allerdings gibt's schon
Schnee und zwar am Freitag da können
hier im Nordosten durchaus einige
Zentimeter Schnee fallen im Südwesten
bleibt's noch milder die gute Nachricht
für die Hochwassergebiete ist der Regen
lässt nach und es wird merärklich kälter
guten
Abend